e aí
e depois de tudo que eu vi eu acho que
vai reforçar aquilo que são poucas as
minhas convicções com todas as
dificuldades que vivemos sejam elas
sociais ambientais econômicas e eu acho
que é um privilégio muito grande viver
este momento porque nunca tivemos estão
próximos nós enquanto pessoas singulares
e tentar promover e até naquilo que nos
é possível a cada um de nós fazer um
mundo melhor e facto eu sou designer de
formação e designer de paixão e sempre
acreditei que o design tem muito mais do
que a capacidade ea competência de fazer
bonito objetos sempre vivi o design com
a missão de poder fazer o mundo melhor
para contextualizar aqui um pouco que eu
vou dizer e vou pedir aqui uma ajuda eu
vou distribuir is os óculos e vou pedir
a quem não tiver coragem de as roubar
somos de volta no final porque eu vou
ter vou precisar deles
é muito rapidamente eu pedi desculpa
e eu deixo estradas todas estas a
e aí eu acho que já toda a gente tem que
é que não tem
e não tiveste
g1
e também não tivesse tu
e aí
g1
se eu pedisse aqui não te vi
e me diz aquilo que sentiu eu tenho mais
óculos e
e no tempo
e então lá
e diga-me diga-me o que sentiu tem que
ser rápido senão tentar quebrar
é ignorado mais quero ouvir uma palavra
excluído ok tá pai tu não precisa mais
palavras era isso que eu queria provocar
eu agora como chama os dez cêntimos
ignorado gostava de sentir-se excluído
eu vou pedir a quem teve os óculos bem
na cara por coitados estes dois foram
ignorados esses excluídos na realidade
foi a maneira que encontrei de poder
fazer núcleos entender sensação de
exclusão ouvir ignorância ignorado
cuidados mas na realidade eu vou
perguntar a quem teve os óculos consegue
identificar a diferença entre estas duas
imagens
o gustavo identifique as um lápis
laranja
se você se identifica facto na realidade
quem foi excluído foi quem teve estes
óculos que foi discriminado foi quem
teve as pessoas óculos eu queria isto
por aqui para poder fazer sentires
naquilo aquilo que é uma limitação com
os olhos não veem falamos 350 milhões de
pessoas em todo o mundo que não vem
corretamente as flores vivemos num mundo
onde noventa porcento da comunicação é
feita através da cor o que procurei
encontrar uma solução que pudesse
minimizar os constrangimentos de todas
estas pessoas que vivem numa sociedade
que como disse vivi da cor mas a
primeira coisa que eu fiz está 20 anos
atrás foi iranete procurar o que que é
isto de ser daltônico encontrei as
coisas mais incríveis que vocês possam
imaginar daltônico era um árbitro que
não marcava um pênalti para o tonico era
um candidato prometeu uma coisa e fazer
outra isso é a universidade para fazer
mestrado e disso eu quero fazer alguma
coisa para daltónicos eu visto
daltônicos
e é como enterro de anão nunca vi nenhum
fato somos condescendentes aquilo que é
uma uma alimentação visível se eu ver um
indivíduo como as calças roxas uma
camisola amarela uma bengala e os óculos
são naturalmente eu vou dizer é para
cuidado é cego mas eu não tiver a
bengala ele é um parolo ela é uma pessoa
de uma rosto falamos de 350 mil pessoas
um em cada dez homens uma em cada 200
mulheres o mundo esqueceu onde
esqueceu-se que a cor era tão importante
do ponto de vista racional identificação
folha e que há pessoas que não haviam
corretamente mas o também que também não
reclamou e não reclama porque porque não
quis assumir a sua condição o que eu
procurei e trabalhei durante 8 anos
neste projeto a criar algo desenvolveu
com daltônicos vários países para mim
era muito importante prestar a questão
cultural poderia ser sou daltônico
portuguesa sentir-se incomodado por usar
uma meia de cada cor mas não algo que é
transversal a todos os países portugal
brasil
a argentina áfrica do sul coreia do sul
estados unidos e terá 90 porcento dos
daltônicos precisa de ajuda para comprar
roupa mesmo tem dessa ajuda na compra
sessenta por cento dos autônomos precisa
de ajuda para escolher a roupa que vai
vestir no dia a seguir mas mais do que
isso 41 porcentos daltônicos tem
dificuldade de integração social em
algum momento da sua vida sentiram a
constrangimento a vergonha para a
autoestima para de autoconfiança
dependência de terceiros que nem sempre
é possível então eu queria saber o que é
que é isto ser daltônico primeiro com
médicos de daltonismo a deixa autonics
iguais não há dois a vários graus de
autonista.me efusivamente divisão a
preto e branco por nós precisamos da
cores não a questão emocional mas a
questão racional da cor é transversal a
todo mundo perguntava aos daltónicos que
eles queriam assumidamente eles queriam
a solução que os permitisse viver no
mundo que comunica pela cor mas sem ter
que assumir e eu sou daltônico então
misturar tudo que eram linguagens
universais
o trânsito código internacional das
bandeiras sinais terrário código o
brasil que eu pensava que era universal
mas não é mas também não é relevante ou
morsa etc e facilmente de um para
perceber que a cor ea forma são os dois
elementos que garantem essa
universalidade sendo que para o caso do
daltônico acordo não poderia aparecer
mas a forma assim volta reagir a forma
como cancional que vocês veem aqui
embaixo do vosso lado direito
a rotam reage a mesma mesmo dentes top
que por acaso melhores volto reagir a
forma então se rechear forma tem a
certeza que poderia encontrar na forma
uma solução para representar a cor o que
é que eu fiz mais do que o dia que a
gente sente porque às vezes da maneira
como queremos ajudar como queremos fazer
são determinantes do ponto de vista de
como interpretar do outro lado eu não
tenho dúvidas quando eu me dediquei a
isto eu queria ajudar o daltônico quero
ajudar o daltônico e quero continuar
ajudar o daltônico mas eu não precisava
de marcar isso
a direita chamado cola rei da cor era
mais jovem mais intuitivo e certamente
que pode autonico que fazia entender
mais o que é que isto era mas era muito
mais por nós aquela ideia lá vem o tipo
de vez com os todas agora ajudar mas as
cores o ed foi determinante porque a
função aquilo que ele conceito que eu
procurei neste processo todo recuperar o
conhecimento adquirido que todos nós
temos da escola certamente nesta sala já
tivemos uma caixinha de guache que eles
disseram que eram as três cores
primárias mais branco e o preto então a
cada uma das três cores primárias outras
na forma mais tempo gráfico é que
cumprir uma série de requisitos primeiro
fácil de integrar vocabulário visual de
cada um independentemente da sua
formação religião cultura geografia
fosse o que fosse fácil de reproduzir em
diferentes dimensões também os e
técnicas mas mais do que isso fácil
desligar entre eles porque por quando
andamos na escola nós aprendemos que ser
mostrar o amarelo com o vermelho eu
tenho laranja sem misturar o verde com o
azul com o amarelo eu tenho ver
e assim mostrar o símbolo amarelo com
símbolo azul eu tenho se mover e com
três símbolos os autores que consegue
identificar todas as cores eu nós vai
ver que ele não vai distinguir um
vermelho ferrari e levar bem né então
mas eu preciso saber que ele é vermelho
e não é verde e tal qual na caixinha dos
guaches amostrar o preto com uma cor eu
tenho uma cor colar o escura se mostrar
o verde com o preto temos o verde escuro
estão escuros se mostrar o branco com
azul eu tenho um azul claro que nos
colares e cinco símbolos permitem que o
daltônico identifique todas as cores foi
uma tese mestrado de 18 anos a fazer
validade pela comunidade científica
através de vários artigos que escrevi
que foram publicados para mim era
importante não seria eu vou dizer que
esperam uma solução era ter temos a
terraça fazer perceber que isto mesmo se
quer uma solução mas para chegar a 350
milhões daltônicos que eu não sei onde
estão porque o também que não tem
escrito na testa e os daltônico é um
processo difícil impossível não iria
andar a bater porta a porta à p
e por isso chegar a 350 milhões de
pessoas é difícil é fácil de chegar a 7
mil milhões de pessoas mas era preciso
montar o jogo e como é que vamos chegar
à cette heure as pessoas não sabemos
como nos aproximar rapidamente deles
sozinhos é impossível então digamos um
modelo e falo no plural que cria uma
equipe que trabalha comigo desde 2010
dedicado implementar e isto em todo o
mundo através de modelos de cocriação
mudar o mundo sozinho impossível não tem
piada nenhuma mas em conjunto acho que é
possível chegar a sete milhões de
pessoas conseguimos cumprir aqui dois
propósitos um garantir uma integração do
daltônico na sociedade sem que não
tivesse que assumir a sua condição como
disse e outro sensibilizar o restante de
noventa porcento da sociedade que existe
pessoas que não vem as cores existe
pessoas que podem perfeitamente ser
integradas numa cidade que vive da cor
sem terem que ser discriminadas
ignorados ou rejeitadas foi importante
criar um modelo sustentabilidade e isso
também no valor porque tem inovação e
pediu
a fast pace inovação puro atrás do calor
e não existia nada uma solução que não é
tecnológica ou seja poderia ter que
parecida a 500 anos atrás não dependendo
da tecnologia todas mais facilmente
poder chegar a todos e chegaram todos no
processo na sua essência na sua génese
de cocriação valorizar através de um
modelo de negócio sustentável em que o
impacto social ao nosso grande objetivo
mas o impacto econômico também é
necessário porque porque só assim
sistemicamente se consegue escalar
garantido aquilo que é introdução de um
terceiro inequação o hino e como fazemos
ou por onde andamos durante quatro anos
dedicamos a testar isso em portugal
valorizando aquilo que era um impacto
diferenciador das empresas no momento de
crise foi importante para nós perto de
casa conseguimos encontrar soluções para
mais do que temos uma boa ideia temos
uma solução efetiva e se falamos de
elevação esse resistência à inovação é
uma coisa natural nós temos que criar
algo que fosse consolidado
um beijo caminhos com solidários no dia
a dia das pessoas pelo mundo e preparar
isso para as futuras gerações alguns dos
exemplos orientação dos hospitais é
feita através da cor do hospital são
joão no porto o primeiro hospital do
mundo adotar esta linguagem na sua
organização facto circulam a 15 mil
pessoas diariamente fizemos pontas a
merceeiro há 750 daltônicos que se
perdem no hospital que não é um sítio
para uma pessoa se perder pensar seguir
a linha amarela para ir à maternidade
ver o filho que nasceu ir parar aquela
sala que tem aquelas arcas frigoríficas
deitadas não é um bom sítio e o custo
isso traz os fármacos hospitalares
evitar aquilo que foi o que aconteceu
ensino santa maria aos anos desde o qual
a rede introduzido nas etiquetas de
forma que se hospitalares para reforçar
a segurança e eliminar o erro ou a
triagem de manchester dar a volta único
conforto de saber se está melhor ou pior
que eu tipo instalado se vai entrar
primeiro na consulta está integrado
também no portal de
a espera do serviço nacional de saúde
mas não é só saúde aos transportes mesmo
tendo o nome mais de cinquenta por cento
dos utilizadores transportes em todo o
mundo usam a cor como um pato um
primeiro fator de diferenciação das
linhas e nos podemos esquecer
maioritariamente assaltarem que são
homens e o homem aquele tipo gosta de
parar perguntar ou seja independência
aquisitiva que precisa no processo claro
que mais do que ter uma boa ideia é
preciso ter alguém que está se tal qual
os provadores nos dos reis estou aqui no
porto funcionou está já na carris em
lisboa trabalhamos já com o processo de
implementação no metro de madrid e algo
que sistemicamente queremos escalar
escalar com regras claras isto é um
projeto ambicioso e não é ganancioso por
isso todo esse processo todas estas pele
hospitalar tem que ser feito com formas
consolidadas não perca este flecha assim
mas para que isto se consiga consolidar
no tempo tal qual temos as instruções de
lavagem nas nossas peças de roupa outros
exemplos as cidades
ou seja no turismo na cultura na
protecção civil nos incêndios na na na
fiscalidade na mobilidade da cor um
fator de extrema relevância na mais hoje
que vivemos no mundo do mundo global os
parques de estacionamento sejam públicos
ou privados a cor definir toda a
organização e um espaço em que
geralmente os layouts são todos iguais
recolha seletiva de resíduos nos
contentores de lixo há bocado de
falar-vos de medicamentos salvos agora
de contentes deles ou seja a cor tem uma
relevância muito grande naquilo que
organização de um mundo que cada vez
mais erro é é global as bandeiras das
praias e quando fiz o estudo trabalhar
com um daltônico de vários países e
perguntar vaz para me inscrever em
situações constrangedoras do seu dia a
dia e um de acordo poderia ser um fator
inibidor dizer uma senhora brasileira
todos os dias que eu sinto meu posto de
trabalho em perigo o patrão e via 16
bordo e diz o contrato está corrigido
que o que é verde é para pôr o que é
vermelha para tirar dizíamos realista
e as bandeiras as bandeiras das praias
tão grande problema e diesel mas para
não pode ser eu sempre vivi no porto
junto do mar basta molhar o estado do
mar se tiver muito picada eu não vou
tomar banho se tiver lisinho eu posso ir
para casa do vô que a água gelada sempre
câncer mas a parte isso eu dizem depois
mas por vezes aqui as águas estão
contaminadas ramos de couro ou
inclusivamente o que aconteceu o ano
passado no algarve com as caravelas de
facto a bandeira tem uma relevância
muito grande em 2016 foram hasteadas as
primeiras bandeiras praias um incremento
a uma boa prática um pouco à revelia
daquilo que é uma convenção
internacional que tem décadas tutelada
nos diferentes países pelas mais
conservadora entidades que o meu caso da
marinha cá em portugal e externos rosto
mais de 500 km pena que estava horror
e ajuda a garantir a independência
física e daltônico uma prática esta que
também já está instalada nas ilhas
canárias em espanha onde morre mais
gente dentro da água do que em acidentes
de automóvel e relevância que a cor tem
naquilo que a independência aquisitiva
de cada um mais semáforo nutricional a
cor quando identifica aquilo que as
características de um alimento o código
está lá apertando as marcas não são
aquilo que é o impacto que possam gerar
do ponto de vista da valorização do
produto da responsabilidade social
corporativa das empresas mas tudo um
processo que nós queremos envolver todos
e modelos de procriação não a ideia de
toma lá vai ajudar não vamos todos fazer
essa mudança
em vários eventos sejam os festivais de
verão sejam eventos desportivos tivemos
e temos parcerias com a liga de clubes
entre organização dos eventos de
distribuição dos adeptos nos estádios é
feita pela cor e seu a vinda da uefa a
portugal ver o que estamos a fazer o o
daltonismo está a agenda da uefa já
conseguimos mudar a cor da bola já
conseguimos mudar a organização dos
equipamentos não que o código seja a
solução para tudo mas não precisamos de
ser a solução para tudo que precisamos é
que a sociedade seja sensível a todo
este processo roupa vestuário como vos
falei é óbvio o impacto nos produtos e
ideia de que é possível de criar
dinâmicas e garantir que o envolvimento
de um segundo setor tem grande impacto
temos por exemplo o exemplo do toyota
começou no verão passado um carro toyota
aygo power bike a lareira ou seja a
personalização de um carro dentro
daquilo que a organização da cor que cor
possa ter tudo isto procuramos que sejam
modelo de alavancar todo o processo
nós trabalhamos com uma regra única não
há exclusividade para ninguém porque
precisamos exclusividade temos a
condicionar aquilo que a liberdade de um
daltônico precisamos uma empresa dizendo
no nosso no nosso setor nós pagamos dez
vezes mais do que vocês querem mas
queremos ser o único durante cinco anos
e nos vemos não isto é para todos tem
que ir por todos e só assim é que vamos
conseguir criar um mundo melhor adiar
que introduzir o código nos seus lápis
recuperar o mercado nacional a
concorrência veio atrás pode tentar
recuperar e dessa maneira conseguimos
ter todos lado do bem um exemplo para
mim muito me sensibilizou e orgulho por
quê porque vem antes do início da
investigação e eu quis ter o mais
importante jogo de cartas do mundo a
utilizar este código a matéria é maior
multinacional de jogos do mundo na
empresa norte-americana o jogo no tenho
46 anos mattel vai ter connosco e disse
queremos encontrar nisto uma solução de
vender 13 milhões de jó
e em 2017 a mattel ações sobre no
mercado com isto comprou ou antes de
frente de vendas em 66 por cento é
possível ganhar dinheiro e fazer o bem e
com isto a sensibilizada e o impacto que
escreveu um produto do maior
multinacional de jogos do produto líder
mundial do mercado fez queima a pele e
este ano de 2019 passar se unem brasil
por quê porque o mundo para daltónicos
teve um grande impacto e dessas maneira
e dessas dinâmicas em que é possível
garantir se consegue criar algo mais
daquilo que é valorização do produto
porém simples mas aquilo que é o
comprometimento com uma sociedade que se
quer mais justa mas está no dia a dia
das pessoas que para nós é importante
porque a autólico de hoje era também
importante levar para as escolas levar
isto as escolas porque o meu daltônico é
vítima de bullying bullying exercido
maioritariamente sem o querer
naturalmente pelo próprio professor
eu não entendo porque é que o meu de
pintar o telhado da casa de verde ou
pintar de vermelho ou não entendi aquilo
que fosse a transformação geopolítica
antes e depois da guerra o mapa
laranjeira verde e de chama de burro
colete está integrado em vários manuais
escolares já ensinado naquelas matérias
ou disciplinas onde é possível ensinar
isto é usado em outras disciplinas onde
é utilizado para ensinar outras matérias
tem portugal em vários manuais escolares
no sistema de ensino da mackenzie e no
brasil da macrilan em espanha nos exames
nacionais e inclusivamente para garantir
que a igualdade a oportunidade de um
time de autonomia e uma interpretação do
enunciado a regulação da resposta mais
de 15 chegarmos as crianças está qual
dele e o o sumo ciclo passo recolha
seletiva em casa mas eu fui educado numa
geração em que se mete o lixo dentro de
um saco não é no rumo no chão mas era
tudo há do mesmo saco mas nós temos
trouxeram uma nova maneira de olhar para
isso as crianças têm essa capacidade de
poder
a sensibilizar influenciar os adultos e
também no processo com esta ideia
criamos uma organização
não-governamental 1mg dedicada às
escolas completamente sustentável e com
um projeto que vai muito mais além do
que o colar e queremos sensibilizar para
a causa queremos precocemente detectar
fazer o rastreio para organismo e
impressionante os daltônicos descobriu
que era daltônico depois de 20 anos de
20 anos sem saber o que que era usado
sem saber que era discriminado sem saber
o que que era vítima de bullying e então
com isso procuramos que todos os miúdos
através de atividades que vamos fazendo
com eles usar os óculos mas eles
perceber que ser autonico não é pior é
diferente eu me daltônico deixa de ser
rejeitado e discriminado e passa a ser
alguém que tem um super poder que tem
uma história diferente para contar uma
maneira diferente de interpretar o pôr
do sol de falar do arco-íris tudo isso
permite com que eu tenho uma integração
muito mais fácil sensibilizando a
comunidade através da comunidade escolar
com estas ações e é muito engraçado
porque vou para a escola de dizem os
miúdos que foi uma linguagem inventada
português os pontos todos pensam que eu
já morri porque porque se inventou
alguma coisa é porque já foi há muito
tempo fazemos like comente das
bibliotecas escolares possível rúcula
aquilo que é uma normativa da unesco a
classificação decimal universal que tem
na cor a diferenciação das diferentes
temáticas fazemos isto também em
moçambique só fizemos e choco e não faz
da faixa de gaza noite ok em gaza com o
911 call crianças que é impressionante
perceber não só a facilidade com que os
professores aderem a isto porque se
facto a cor tem uma relevância muito
grande até mesmo no desenvolvimento
cognitivo das crianças por isso os
teletanbes um tão feinhas eles gostam de
todos os deles mas também trabalhar com
os miúdos perceber o impacto tem fizemos
também o tamanho no sul da índia era
importante irá situações mais difíceis
daquilo que é os problemas locais e nem
na índia até que fruto da diabetes o
daltonismo tem uma incidência muito
grande
é mas esta zona nas famílias viver com
seis dólares por mês impressionante de
dar e entender aquilo como é fato fazer
e como é fácil roubar no bom sentido o
sorriso a uma criança basicamente é isso
que nós estamos a fazer é isso que vamos
continuar a fazer e aqui uma coisa
engraçada já agora um pequeno desafio
veja um se consegue identificar quem
este personagem está interessante não
vai ter uns óculos não chegam lá com os
óculos é interessante para perceber nos
estigmas disto organismo certamente se
obra deste homem fosse vendida sabemos
que era daltônico vale a metade com o
que vale e importante perceber o impacto
constrangimento que o daltônico que o
daltonismo tem aquilo que é o dia a dia
das pessoas ninguém quer chegar lá
eu trabalhei durante os tempos com um
dos mais conceituados oftalmologistas do
mundo que está ali estava a desenvolver
investigação sobre van gogh precisamente
o daltonismo do van gogh claramente
identificado a única de dúvida que a ec
de queridos isso veio de nascença ou se
foi adquirido processo de consumo da
muito ou até do próprio chumbo das
tintas mas de fax softalm lojista disse
uma coisa que me enquanto o designer
número com muito no motivou a continuar
caminho colar ele foi o primeiro
medicamento criado pelo designer e facto
de poder olhar para isto e perceberes e
a pergunta é recorrente se eu sou
daltônico não eu não sou daltônico e
acho que o fato da nossa daltônico é que
fez com que este projeto ou que este
solução o que esta inovação e veste o
impacto que está ter no mundo porque se
fosse daltônico eu queria queria eu ia
criar um uma solução para resolver o meu
problema o meu grau de altruísmo o facto
de não ser fez com que eu tivesse te
procurar
o hospital tem just a entender
claramente como é que eles vivem como é
que eles resolveram o que prova que nós
somos muito mais competentes fizemos as
coisas a pensar nos outros porque a
pensar nos e nós obrigado aí
[Música]